you've mentioned something about schnoor
and taproot
um what are your thoughts about this
update to bitcoin
and in terms of its promise to improve
privacy and scaling
and so on and what what other things are
you interested
excited about in terms of the
development of bitcoin
well schnorr and top root that's the
first new protocol upgrade
since segwit uh in 2017 which was what
um laid the groundwork for lightning to
be developed basically
and schwartapri is really the first
protocol change
in three almost four years now so it's
we're very excited about it what uh what
are
i mean is there any something
interesting to say technically about
what are the things that's actually
going to improve
and um maybe on a on the politics side
bringing a protocol change
uh on bitcoin what does that actually
involve
yeah i mean it's a huge deal because the
last time we tried to make a change to
the protocol we had a whole civil war
over it
and it was incredibly difficult to get
segwit activated in 2017
uh and it took all this bricksmanship
and threats and all these campaigns
and it was this whole thing luckily i
think things have quieted down and
there's much more consensus that schnorr
top rate is a good change to bitcoin and
everyone generally supports it
but everyone kind of has ptsd over the
last time
when we tried to change bitcoin and so
we're sort of really dithering over how
we actually want to implement it
so it's taking forever because we're
trying to set the protocol
for how do you change bitcoin itself and
that
all of our assumptions went out the
window last time so we're trying to
reset and decide
what is a legitimate way to institute a
change to bitcoin
so that's actually the big question
right now it's not should we implement
these changes we basically all agree
that we should
it's a meta question is what's the valid
way to implement new changes to bitcoin
what's a way that is scalable in the
long term and will last and people
consider credible
even if this one isn't controversial at
all so that's
where we're at we're basically debating
over how do we implement this change
that we all want
if you to get a feeling of how slow
bitcoin governance is and how deliberate
it is
everybody collectively wants the change
but we haven't fully agreed on how we're
going to put it into bitcoin
so it's a classic sort of bitcoin
situation
but what it is is i mean schnoor is an
alternative signature scheme i think it
was encumbered by a patent
and it had only just been unencumbered
when satoshi created bitcoin i believe
it's a better signature scheme than
elliptic curves which is what
big than ecdsa which is what bitcoin
uses
and uh so it's been long enough that we
now trust it
you know kind of in cryptography it's
meant to be lindy you know it's sort of
you want to test it over time and then
it's considered safe to use so schnoor
has been around for long enough that
we've decided to rip out ecdsa
and insert schnorr which is just a
different signature scheme which is more
efficient
and it has better properties like if you
want to do a multi-signature transaction
where
many people collectively sign in order
permission to spend
that would be more efficient in a bytes
sense
than ecdsa for instance so it's pretty
incremental
and then taproot is all about um
having transactional conditions
that are sort of withheld from final
entry onto the blockchain
um so it it's kind of a way to
um have more private conditional
transactions
on bitcoin uh so both of them i would
say are incremental
uh changes is this an over exaggeration
that channel taproot might improve
privacy and scaling
which is it like at the high level
things that people mention
is that just like a dramatic way of of
trying to frame
uh what's fundamentally an incremental
improvement
yes but incremental is the word right
it's not we're not going to get an order
of magnitude enhancement to either
privacy or scaling
but we will get a considerable
enhancement
uh but privacy and scaling are actually
two sides the same coin because
you get more transactional privacy by
removing data from the ledger
so that there's less metadata for people
to surveil and analyze
and that's also you scale by compressing
and being really space efficient with
transactions and the more parsimonious
you are
the more economically dense each bite
that everyone has to retain on the
ledger is
and so those are you know very closely
allied concepts
you